what keeps you here now in Los Angeles
good question um I love the city and
I've been lucky enough that I came here
my brother lived here but now pretty
much my whole family has moved here so
now I have family here so it's a little
different my sister's here my younger
sister and my parents are in Palm Desert
so it's not far so family in a way would
keep me here no matter what but I love
Los Angeles it's such a sprawled out
city there's all these different pockets
of cool things to do or hikes or
whatever so and the weather is beautiful
so you know I don't try to promote it I
never I never try to get more people to
move here because so many people move
here already so but a lot of people move
back back home yeah a lot of people give
up too and move away but because of the
weather I feel like a lot of people
moved to Los Angeles in general sure but
no I I'm in the mecca of moviemaking in
the United States I mean that's where
Los Angeles is so I don't know what kind
of trials and tribulations you'd have if
you were in Atlanta or somewhere else
maybe there there's enough people that I
wouldn't you know you have enough film
people but here I mean in my phone I
have 10 DPS I can call directors of
photography writing calling they own a
camera in a new mean so it's like here
there's so many people that are making
films there's so many people to own
cameras it's really saturated so to get
a project off the ground off the ground
it's a lot easier to get it off the
ground as to we're in the middle of
America do you know anyone that owns a
red camera or already Alexa or any of
these kind of cameras it's probably
really hard to find somebody that owned
one owns one in like Nebraska or
something so here you're in a bar you
probably somebody in the bar why don't
your camera I mean it's just so it's so
saturated in that way so hopefully
they're sober enough to operate it but
yeah but do you have a goal list like do
you have a certain amount of things that
you know by this date I want to have
them completed I mean I want to make 30
movies in my life probably its whatever
inspires me really I mean I have
in my phone I have ideas for movies that
go on and on I mean I must have 20 or 30
ideas for features some are fleshed out
and some are really raw just a one or
two sentences but I also have a TV show
like I did so I came here and I worked
for DreamWorks and I worked for Todd
Phillips and then I realized it's funny
because I realized that people around me
had want to be directors or they want to
be some position in film and they
weren't doing it yet and I was like how
long have you worked here and oh I've
been doing this 11 years but I want to
be a film director and I was like so I
could be you in 11 years I was like yeah
I got a stop so when I left Todd
Phillips his office I was like I want to
act interact so I went to acting school
and I started acting in every possible
thing I could I did 11 short films in
2009 and then I was a lead in three
independent feature films in 2010 and
when I saw the independent feature films
I realized they weren't good enough and
I thought to myself I have to get behind
the camera if I really want to make my
dreams come true and I always planned on
getting behind the camera anyway
eventually but it just kind of pushed me
to do it sooner so I thought I was just
gonna produce an act and so I put I
managed to raise the money together to
shoot a TV pilot and I was gonna produce
we had a director and everybody
the director pulled out and it was his
script so I told the money people hold
on I'll write something else and we can
shoot that so I ended up writing three
guys in a couch which is a TV pilot that
I wrote and and ended up directing
because I couldn't find a director
everybody couldn't see the vision that I
had so I ended up directing it too so I
acted and directed and wrote it and we
shot it in 2011 it's actually on Amazon
Prime you can go watch it on Amazon
Prime and it's for free on there and
it's a 20 minute pilot it's a comedy
pilot I kind of I love Seinfeld growing
up and so it was kind of my newer
version of Seinfeld you know my best
version of it I guess that I can do and
it's just about three guys trying to
rent out their couch for to make rent so
I think the whole episode just couch
interviews they're interviewing people
to rent the couch so that was the pilot
episode and I have God I have in my
phone like 50 episodes of that show I
just kept writing ideas for that show in
that shower gel so hopefully I do
another show and use all those ideas
eventually but I did that TV pilot was
the first thing I ever directed and then
I ended up from that pilot someone at
Fox saw it and Fox called me and it was
like hey it was a subsidiary of Fox but
it's on the Fox lot called me and it was
like hey we'd really like to develop a
new show with you like this was really
good for your first thing so let's let's
develop something else so I came in
every week for like eight or nine months
developing new ideas with them for new
shows and eventually settling on a show
called parole officers which is about a
guy who gets arrested and he gets to
parole officers that are gonna help him
change his life background but he gets
he got falsely arrested for drugs so he
really has no problem with drugs and the
two parole officers are completely crazy
that take over his life and just totally
destroyed even more so we shot that into
that well hold on rewind Fox ended up
scheduling him for me to do a table read
they were like we're gonna give me a
million dollar budget to do the pilot
all this kind of stuff and then they
ended up pulling the plug and so the day
before the table read they were like we
have something similar now we're not
going to shoot this anymore what they
did not know is every time I would come
in with a script or an idea we're not an
idea but a script I was copy writing it
so I are I knew that I owned the
copyright on the show so okay you have
something similar but you're not gonna
steal my idea so I was like heartbroken
for a while I mean it's hard to get over
was eight or nine months you know of me
telling my friends and everyone I'm
doing a show with Fox you didn't read it
so for me it was like it was very
heartbroken when it didn't happen but
then I was like you know what I'm gonna
shoot myself so three guys in a couch we
shot for five grand at the time
on the red cameras so this I actually
ended up shooting for five grand as well
it's a 27 minute pilot that's also on
Amazon Prime now parole officers and so
I ended up raising the money
independently and we shot that TV pilot
as well in 2013 and then from there
there was I ended up directing two short
films for friends and then it was like
it's time to do a feature so that's when
while I got wasted got made so I'm
hoping we can go back to when you worked
at Todd Phillips's office and at what
point did you have that like wow I could
be this person here or this person here
and they seemed happy with their job
maybe not maybe they are but I don't
want to have that be me how did you like
what can you kind of take us through how
long before you left I think in the
beginning I think in the beginning it
was just so exciting to be there I mean
like Angelina Jolie would come in the
office you know like Angelina Jolie was
in the hallway and I'm like oh there's a
pretty girl in the hallway and then
she's standing out there for a while I'm
like maybe this woman's lost you know
I'll go out there she was pregnant at
the time this pregnant woman's in the
hallway like maybe she's lost so I went
in the hallway I'm like hey you okay
like you lost and of course once I get
in the hallway I'm like oh I'm talking
to Angelina Jolie she's like no I'm just
waiting I'm gonna go to a meeting
upstairs and I just wanted a moment by
myself and I was like okay no problem
you know I walked back in the office
she's right on the other side of the
class to me you know and there's no one
else around
so of course I'm I go you know Angelina
Jolie's here on the computer you know
telling the office and then like the guy
played Hellboy at the time he was come
in the office like and I met so many
people coming in the office that were
making movies and actors and so in the
beginning it was just so exciting to be
there you know on the post side of
things I never would meet movie stars or
I mean I met Steven Spielberg in that
but I wouldn't meet like Angelina Jolie
at DreamWorks at post-production they
just don't go there but there was just
so exciting I think it took a while for
the excitement to wear off because I was
doing script coverage on like three
scripts a day they would expect three
scripts a day for me to read and do
coverage on them and and I'm a slow
reader too so it wasn't easy for me but
constantly trying to break it down and
write a
you know of one-page synopsis of the
whole movie and and green-lighted or not
greenlight like if you didn't get
through me the people above me never
read it so that's how it would work so
if I don't like your script the person
above me doesn't like the scripts and
I'm never gonna read the script you know
and then on top of that it was just kind
of crazy to me in a way because these
people have agents their managers there
but if you don't get through the guy at
the front desk you don't get to Scott
Budnick at the time or Todd Phillips or
anyone else so I'm literally like green
letting someone's life or not but if I
send it up the ladder and it's not good
my now I'm not considered a very good
script coverage guy so your own my own
ass is on the line
so it was very interesting at the time I
think it took three months before the
excitement of it all war of everything
kind of wore off and I started asking
more questions you know and Todd
Phillips assistant at the time was his
assistant for like nine years and I
found out he was a film director and I
saw some commercials he shot and some
other stuff and he was like yeah I want
to be a film director and I was like but
you've been his assistant for nine years
like clearly he's not gonna help you
make a film you know so he's not gonna
help me make a film I got to go make a
film out on my own so that's kind of the
epiphany that I had that no one here if
you're not doing the job that you're
supposed to be doing they can't see like
something I've learned in Hollywood
since I've been here people don't see
potential it's not something that they
see it's either you've done it or you
haven't done it it's very rare that
someone can see potential of what you've
done
like there's no excuses it's like you've
even they're made in a phenomenal movie
or you've made a mediocre movie and then
they think you're gonna always make a
mediocre movie so or I guess in any
position that you've done they could
they don't see potential like oh you had
a really good moment here or there or
your budget you didn't have enough money
they don't see the excuses it's either
it's good enough or it's not why do you
think that is do you think it's because
there's just everything goes too fast
and there's too much money on the line
they don't have time to like nurture
something or
I think it might have been different
back in the day they might have nurtured
people more back in the day I mean like
all the studios now are corporate I mean
like Viacom you know like all these big
companies own the studios it's not
really owned by an individual anymore
back in the day paramount was it
paramount I think was owned by a guy
that would go to all the premieres with
a lion I mean it was one person's
decision and a few people belong and I
think in was that the 90s or something I
mean all the studios got bought up by
big corporate companies everything's
powered by money so since everything is
powered by money are you gonna take a
chance on someone who's already
delivered or someone who has potential I
mean if your ass is on the line you're
gonna go with the safe bet so part of me
understands that but I think also it
takes a very special person to see
potential you know I I don't think
everyone can see potential it's about is
it it's almost a rare skill compared to
the talent like only some people are
very very talented some people only have
that one gift of seeing talent too
and half the people that I meet that are
at the top still they don't have that
gift like they shove twenty forty
million dollars in advertising on a
movie in the movie my bomb well somebody
else might have been able to see that it
was gonna bomb but they couldn't see it
but they have the title of the head of
the studio or whatever so it's just
interesting to see how certain things
happen and I know people in positions
that tell me all kinds of stories were
you know I'm like really I saw the
trailer to that I have no idea what that
movies about and it's a two minute
trailer like if I don't know what your
movies about at all and it's a two
minute trailer it's a really bad sign
you know and you're putting 40 million
dollars in advertising that blows my
mind
but anyway
you